en 1766 à versailles sont construits les
carrés de saint louis un édifice qui
accueillera des abreuvoirs une fontaine
d'eau potable mais aussi un château
d'eau au temps de louis 15 la mairie
récupérera le bâtiment dans les années
30 qui deviendra un cabinet d'architecte
aujourd'hui le cube est devenu un nouvel
espace dédié à l'art
ça faisait donc pas mal d'années que cet
espace était et est entre guillemets
abandonné et donc là on est en train de
leur transformer je dirais en lieu
d'accueil en lieu d'exposition
donc ça permet comme ça de revivifier à
la fois la place et de revivifier en
plus je dirais le quartier qui demande
un clémente que 100 avant d'en faire une
salle d'exposition le cube a été fermé
pendant trois ans toute l'année la
galerie recevra différents artistes pour
des expositions mais aussi des ateliers
pour les enfants et des ateliers lecture
prudente envers ceux qui ne connaissent
pas l'intérieur de ce lieu tout le monde
passe devant sans savoir ce qu'il en est
les saints lieu qui est vraiment
atypique avec une architecture moderne à
l'intérieur alors que le bâtiment est
vraiment du xviie à ses anciens depuis
le début du mois de décembre 40 dessins
sur la vie de saint-exupéry fait par
l'artiste cédric fernandes sont proposés
au public
dans cette nouvelle adresse culturel et
dans cette exposition sont proposés des
dessins originaux
ce sont les véritables planches de
l'artiste avec lesquels il a travaillé
pour faire donc ces trois volumes de
saint-exupéry on y retrouve évidemment
le monde de l'aviation
voilà tous les éléments autour de
saint-exupéry ils sont proposés à la
fois en dessin noir et blanc mais aussi
des illustrations couleur l'exposition
saint-exupéry le seigneur des sables est
disponible jusqu'au 28 décembre au cube